I'm black I'm black I'm black I'm black
I'm black I'm black I'm white
I'm white
you know this video the way it starts is
really weird because if you need to know
what this was about
I'm black I'm black I'm black I'm black
I'm black I'm black I'm white and I love
black men
I'm white
yeah sometimes they do Fitzy sometimes
they be doing Fitzy I think my strategy
was to kind of just just be black I'm
not gonna lie when you said Fitz I
thought it was because you had tough
fits on you know I mean
if I wasn't even funny can we all see
this guy's idea of trying to blood dance
a black dude is being a hater
and I think it's gonna work
everybody else
now all black people don't go to church
now but they notice this is true what
flavor of Kool-Aid was your favorite
growing up red red that's the only
that's the only flavor that was
in purple
a lot of me there was no yellow it was
red the Kool-Aid Man the red it's like I
like grape mean purple
purple
was not great but it was purple he said
great you mean purple we got some great
drink no no I want some of that grape
juice nah we got that purple stuff
yeah that's kind of suspicious
where I'm from we go by colors we don't
go by we don't go by that what you just
said wait wait hold up why is that it's
crazy because grape and purple exactly
the same you don't even know why that
crazy
and the white boy is shutting the [__]
up right now you're doing the smart
stuff no he's about to bury him he said
I smelled blood in the water you a
little too white my half white brother I
mean we used to call we used to call
Welch's grape soda I don't know it's
just where I'm from we go by colors
speaking of Welch's you remember that
commercial the one with this kid
pull that [__] up some juice drinks only
have a little bit of juice in them a lot
of other stuff but not well juice
Welch's grape juice it's 100 juice from
real concord grapes then I have to add a
lot of other stuff well just concord
grapes give it a taste you can feel in
your cheeks Welch's grape juice this kid
was great that's a nasty you know I mean
I mean I do at wreath but this kid [__]
everyone from like hey if you were born
in the 90s you remember that kid but it
was good when it comes to black women
from the 90s who do you think of offer
it be alone yeah I was about to say
[Music]
that I still do good I gotta agree yo
man eating you alone can get it for me
it was always Toni Braxton yes everyone
got their thing it's kind of came after
though
she came after I think her no yesterday
but she was the first one with this one
but yeah Tony Braxton was yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely Unbreak Ma and
even you know what and it was he wasn't
man the first the first one I wore
before Rihanna could run was Tyra Banks
with the big ass forehead I'm growing up
watching my sisters Raven Simone Tyra
Banks from
Raven nah nobody was on Ray That's So
Raven
appreciate y'all what was one of y'all
favorite movies growing up you feel me
like loving basketball don't be a menace
I mean what did y'all watch I like New
Jack City like that was all right you
from New York yeah so you already know
like I am My Brother's Keeper and that's
some real [__] so I'll tell you what man
I'll watch the uh the first Power
Rangers movie like twice a day for like
the first four years after it came out
man Power Rangers yeah Power Rangers
what season what season oh yo you good
he's good all right
Power Rangers yeah that didn't sound
kind of sucks this guy's key in there he
says this guy gets it yeah Mighty
Morphin Mighty Morphin is hard it is
y'all know about that static shock
though come on I was literally just
about to say no I said Superheroes
static shots I'm not gonna let static
shock was a big deal for me too growing
up not gonna lie I was nostalgic as [__]
for me yeah because it was the first
time I seen some black superheroes on
the screen static shot was just jumping
on [__] trash can beans running
around catching people and he was cool
too yeah it was a good show it was a
good show okay so in regards to dating
and whatnot my first girlfriend she
ended up being a Russian girl did your
parents or you know family members like
say hey like I mean my mother was from
Freeport so you know she used to be on
that uh and she was older when she had
me she was already like in her late 50s
so okay she wasn't playing with none of
that really I don't think my parents
ever put they just want me to love who I
love but at the same time I think
there's always that underlying like you
know we would love for it to be a black
woman you know what I mean yeah this
dude is plank like he's smooth he's
throwing ins but he's not he's not he's
not doing anything that's gonna suffer
yeah yeah
honestly if I was on this panel I would
probably fail he's doing really good
yeah if I'm being honest with y'all I
don't think I'd be able to suss him up
we have a tie between Rob
and Brevin
y'all relief
ah okay I'm Brevin I'm from Louisville
Kentucky like I said
um I didn't have a traditional like
upbringing as far as like dating
um a lot of different people because I
am a queer black man but it took me a
long time to get there but as far as
home life I had two parents uh two older
brothers a little sister I'm super close
yeah
um this is hard I don't know I'm black
y'all I'm black my name Robert I'll go
by Rob I'm from South Central L.A we
bounced all around it was just me and my
mother three sisters and two brothers
I've been in and out the streets uh not
too much school and that's pretty much
it
when it came to Brevin it seemed like he
was privileged and I relate more to
struggle hearing some of the things he
was saying it kind of like made me think
in my second guess
my brain I was like this is probably
just like one of those cases where you
could be white and he's just a product
of his environment Brevin you can't vote
[Laughter]
it looks like we are tied again wow what
I voted to Rob just because I think I
heard everyone else speak a little bit
more I also voted Rob first of all you
know I I'm just gonna say that like the
environment he grew up with now I'm
saying I think that like you know that's
just a case where he could like relate
to a lot of like black people's
struggles you feel me but he might not
be like black in and of himself I voted
for Brevin to get out
um not because Brevin necessarily said
anything bad but it was more so because
of when Rob was talking I felt like I
was listening to one of my cousins talk
um
and he definitely sounds like he's from
South Central for sure that don't mean
it's a small percentage Yeah that and
that don't even mean that he's
from there yeah maybe he lying so we
don't know so we don't know we'll see so
I'ma say he stays Rob black that's it
yeah I know that's a fact Rob black
[Laughter]
that's my favorite yo yo get your right
black in that [__] now we not having no
conversation that's a [__] he black and
he ain't and we done with this
conversation and he ain't no no there's
no conversation if he leave I'm shooting
this whole [__]
I know that's a fact Rob black you sound
like people from out my way so he
said no offense to you but but you gotta
kick rocks but you gotta Kick rock is
that what he said
he's out
here
I hear that voice
for sure but Rob like I feel like I
could say certain things to Rob and he'd
pick up on it quick if I say something
certain things to the others like I want
you to know and I think I actually think
this might be the most important flash
point in this whole [__] video yeah
this shows you yeah
if you took away [__] eyes
would you relate what you realize is
they don't relate to each other on a
skin basis no they actually roll each
other on a social economic basis the
reason why it feels understood is like
he grew up in the same environment as
well he grew up in the same kind of poor
kind of [__] up area and so that's why
we get an understanding and that's why I
told people this before it's like
interesting that we all identify each
other as race a lot of times but if you
pay attention people actually just
identify with what's around them more
than anything else that's why a black
dude living in the suburbs is gonna have
way less in common with this guy right
than a white dude who lives in his
neighborhood the reason being is just
because of environment and that's how a
lot of us ever Shake we might all be
black we might all but like if you're
Nigerian African it's different if
you're a black dude from the south
versus a black dude from the north
versus a black dude from Florida like
listen Florida [__] got their own
haircuts and let me tell you [__]
everywhere else like what the [__] is
that right is is this is a different
thing about Wicks my [__] you don't
like Wicks bro that [__] looked like a
prison sentence for hair
does [__] look like an acorn locked up
because I don't know what the [__] is
what his hair his hair about my
brother's hair like that so we talk
about myself don't be talking about
myself like that oh I don't care if
you're those I don't care who they are
that hair looks stupid
it does when I see like a whole and then
a here and then here and that [__] nappy
as [__] it looks silly I think I look
stupid that's me personally again black
people gonna disagree what
you don't think that clown here look
crazy you would the sideshow boy here
yeah I will I will hold up no you got
the hair of a natural clown and then
you're gonna be yeah that's why my dude
that's not even what that's not even one
that's not even what Houston I'll put up
the pictures of the news from Florida
with a crazy hair y'all let me know it's
not crazy I think preachers can't I
think preach doing a little bit of brown
nosy because you know something yeah a
little bit because that is clown hair I
don't know nobody that has hair like
that that is clown hair but the the one
[__] you had Sideshow Bob here so
literally it's an F Well it's fine it's
that's not an afro there's levels
there's levels I will never accept that
my hair looks anything as crazy as that
leaves cause guess what I used to walk
around and nobody really said but them
[__] didn't walk anywhere here nobody
want to say much
all this to say I think that's what's
most interesting about this and it's
made with the most revealing and that's
the reason why that's the reason why
people when I wasn't cool Todd I was too
white yeah because when I went when I
changed from uh when I changed from I
was too black for private school but too
white for uh public school yeah I went
to public school I was probably one day
one of the only kid that I was one of
the only black kids that lived in a
house house one of them not all of them
a lot of them like lived in a house but
whatever two parent households and stuff
like that like that and they showed you
know I mean so
and it's there's a prevention of people
that that were a little bit that had a
little bit more money and stuff like
that I remember that that they when they
were Haitian they would the parents
would tell the kids they were not able
to speak
Creole just to have a like a better
level of French sure so I was like I was
I used to hang out with my sister my
sister always putting out big words and
[__] like that so I'll take it out from
her but then I pop that [__] out high
high school yeah and it sounds like they
were like you're corny yeah so it goes
even a step further because think about
it right people overlap
all this language and culture with race
not realizing the at its exception the
reason why it was racially charged was
because a lot of black people just lived
around each other yeah as these
neighborhoods involved more people from
different communities you recognize that
everyone adopted the same vernacular
irrespective of what they look like a
lot of times so
what this means is now people are being
denied their Blackness because they grew
up in the in the suburbs or because they
grew up in a good area and that's why
you got uh what's that Kali larae trying
to sound like she's shooting up spot
where she lives whatever so she sounded
like she's shooting at a spot when she
lived behind a keypad in a gated
community that's right because in order
for her to feel black and Tourette she
feels like she gotta be street right
because we've keep gladness to to that
if you don't have the vernacular if you
don't talk about the same [__] you corny
you're not even black right and that's
why you got [__] in the hood who made
me have grown up in bad circumstances
but maybe they choose a different way of
speaking or maybe they're Highly
Educated because they've got good
scholarships and they're being called
not black because they've not adopted
that stereotype
Even In This Moment they're saying the
white dude is black because he talks to
specifically and the black dude isn't
black because he's rich or he comes from
a good family it's a fascinating thing
it's going out to be rich it's not even
the question Rich my parents were not
rich yeah we were just
better off than other people and it was
not even Rich they built something but
when I was in high school they were not
rich they didn't have what they have now
they were definitely in a better
position than some other parents you
know not being in a single [__] and
stuff like that so no it was not
richness I've seen some people that were
rich rich is relative so rich in
relativity to most other immigrant
Haitians or black families probably yeah
but it was not me that was rich it was
them that was poor
yes but rich is relative so when black
people are comparing you they're not
comparing you to white folks they're
comparing you to other black people yeah
your family was rich in comparison to
other black families true so that's what
it really comes down to they're not
comparing you to Asians they're not
comparing you to other groups they're
not so were you rich technically yes by
that standard but anyways by the
standard of the bills that we had to pay
and stuff like that so also we were also
considered bougie for the things that my
parents were doing because they were
really uh they were taking trips they
wanted us to like they would sacrifice a
whole lot of their money to be like you
know what we need to educate you on the
world and stuff like that oh we're gonna
go to uh I used to go on on on on field
trips with my dad uh in the summer
so we used to go to museums we used to
go to the Ottawa Museum so whenever so
whenever so whenever my so whenever my
uh whatever my actually whenever I went
to these museums with my with my with my
class i'da already went hey let me just
say this bro that's that's funny to me
because we have the opposite experience
every time field trips would come around
I like there's okay there was the people
that could go and the people who
couldn't go the only difference was
whose parents were gonna pay so you can
get lunches and everything else paid for
on the trip and so you have to give them
money yeah every time the trip would go
it would be all the white kids leaving
and all the [__] staying behind every
single time and I'll never forget this
one time one of the black kids his name
was Hussein he said I want to go skiing
too we said bro don't do it he said my
mom paid we going skiing we said cool
[__] came back in a wheelchair
[__] came back in a wheelchair we said
how was that scared did you leave your
knee behind hey let me tell you bro he
paid to go take an injury yeah that's a
crazy yeah
if your mama pays if you're if you're an
immigrant your mama paid and you go out
there
and she comes back with a hospital bill
your your knees are [__] up but you're
getting [__] up too oh you're getting
that whooping I'm not going to no
emergence emergency and then you gonna
call me when I'm at work I gotta go get
your ass hey never that was the last
time you were going
next time you stay in your style you you
say you're leaving your ass and your
wheels at home he was the eldest of
seven best believe none of his younger
siblings you [__] it up for everybody
yeah
anytime his younger siblings wanted to
go anywhere she pointed at the other
kids and he's like who stupid
but it was yeah take them crutches with
you
take me away
yeah Rob sound like he no good catfish
I'm not sure why I got voted out I feel
that a lot of times I've felt that I'm
too white for the black people and too
black for the white people but it's okay
it's all what did we just tell you
I think the mole is still in the box and
you want to continue playing the game
raise your hand
no stop what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing I knew I wasn't
gonna get eliminated
um why is that
I don't know I just came in like I was
gonna win really Hardy said I was going
to win so what do you do yeah he's had
he said I could have got away with a
robbery but let me go for a second Bank
we go get this money
let's make things a little bit spicy you
feel me what's like one critique and or
what's one thing that you think like
black people could be like doing better
or like a hot take about like black
people and you know the gang banger
no more I mean
uh if you think about it you gangbanger
uh and then it got so bad where you you
know everybody that run black in prison
is together even if you from the enemy
side upside or anything so if you go to
prison so if I if I supposed to gang
bang shoot somebody and if I get caught
and I gotta go to prison and get along
with the people who I just slid on it
don't make no sense and there's no money
involved
feel that don't be so quick to buy
them [__] is like yo I think he too
streak free I don't know what the [__]
are you talking about
like
[Music]
yeah
Hey
listen Jay about to get eliminated I
want to see black people doing goofy
stuff on screen not just being slaves
you know right come on now talk about it
or criminals or or other gangsters or
don't forget about the gangster
[Laughter]
don't forget about the gangsters
oh
sorry Gabriel you know it happens
come on over here if you think the mole
is still in the box and you like to
continue the game raise your hand
three
two one
it is red that means the mall is still
here
[__] I do it yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
I feel like Rob really gangbang and some
part of him was finishing this video be
like ma'am Robinson [__] is so easy
[Music]
of course there's been like a couple
white boys who cool but like not like
Rob like that was different my name is
Robert but uh they called me milk I'm
from South Central I got adopted at
seven days old as a baby like out the
hospital to a black mother so I was
raised with her every since seven days
old that's crazy my whole family was
black I didn't even know the other I
never met the other people until I was
like that's dope grown wrong my
upbringing was a little strange I was
the only white kid at every party every
birthday but I never really that never
really like bothered me I guess is it
hard for you to fit in with white people
oh it was it's getting a little better
what about for black people then is it
easier or it's more difficult to get
along no no no
I mean that's all I was around my whole
life
County jail juvenile hall every party
everything and your whole family like
they just all accept you because I got
signs of my white family that like they
wouldn't even hold me as a baby because
I had a black death not hell no no I had
a good family since my mom married a
black man they sat shibbets for her
which basically in the Jewish community
means that you're dead to me and it's
almost um
lone feeling that you get sometimes when
you feel like you can't relate to
anybody and to reward your mom you
tattooed your neck
hey my [__] you got any yeah you got
eliminated the first round nobody's
trying to see you cry
imagine being on X Factor getting
eliminated during audition you crying no
no don't keep them tears for you it's a
sad story but you didn't earn it you
gotta at least make it to round three I
mean hey [__] that I got limited the
first five minutes of a 30 minute video
that's crazy and I'm crying yeah it
could be me
not crying I'm sorry for what happened
to your mom anyways I thought this was a
good video I really enjoyed it but maybe
y'all felt differently let us know in
the comments below we want to hear from
you